[Music]
Are you feeling overwhelmed from work,
struggling to stay on top of all your classes?
Maybe everything is happening all at once.
They say that when it rains it pours.
When you're feeling low, it's easy to convince
yourself to stay there.
After all, how can you fall when you're already
on the ground?
Nevertheless, your heart wants to heal so
give it what it wants.
Help yourself get back on your feet with these
five self-care tips when you're feeling broken.
One; step outside for some fresh air.
Our thoughts can be even louder than the ruckus
of busy cities.
Whether you're still a student in school or
constantly working in front of a computer,
it's easy to feel congested by deadlines,
projects and never-ending tasks.
Make use of your mornings, lunch breaks and
evenings when you're off the clock to step
outside for walks.
This will help clear your head and improve
your mood.
In Japan, going for walks in the woods is
called shinrin-yoku, which means taking in
the atmosphere of the forest.
In one study at Kyoto University, researchers
discovered that the scent of fresh pine helps
reduce one's levels of anxiety and depression.
Spending time outdoors also helps improve
our concentration.
We aren't meant to experience life in stuffy
bubbles, even if you can't step outside right
away, crack open a window when you can and
allow nature to heal you.
Two; take a nap.
When we don't get enough sleep, our moods
can take a turn for the worse and spiral down
into an endless abyss.
If you're feeling cranky from exhaustion,
take some time, even if it's just half an hour
to curl up on the couch and close your eyes.
There's no shame in closing the curtains,
flicking off the lights and allowing yourself
to recharge.
Once you wake up, you'll feel better rested
and you'll make up for lost time by carrying
out your daily tasks with a fresh and sharp
mind.
Three; allow yourself to be ordinary. We are
all perfectly imperfect.
Take a break from using Instagram filters
and Facebook posts that show your life only
at its best.
Social media is a place where we can share
our favorite moments with others but it has
also become a platform where people feel pressured
to compete with others.
Sometimes, it feels more like a beauty pageant
instead of a second home.
You don't owe anyone a performance.
Your sense of self is worth more than a digitalized
reputation, embrace your flaws and allow yourself
to be average, simple and sincere is always
better.
Four; clean and give your space a makeover.
Cleaning doesn't have to be overly excessive
to make a difference. Whether it means organizing
your bookshelf or clipping your favorite photos
onto the wall, changes, big or small can enhance
the atmosphere.
After all, you spend a lot of time in your
space.
Giving it some love and attention can go a
long way.
Five; reach out and tell someone about what
you've been going through. Feeling down often
leads to shutting down.
We fear burdening others and as this develops
into a habit, we suffer silently making it
harder to heal.
Don't feel ashamed about your struggles, sometimes
you just need someone to hear your story.
You'd be surprised with how much people understand
you.
As a bonus, you'll also end up strengthening
your relationships.
What do you do to take care of yourself when
you feel broken?
Please share your thoughts with us below.
Also don't forget to subscribe for more content
from psych2Go and check out our Patreon.
Thanks for watching!
Hey everybody I just want to give a personal
thank you video for you guys for always supporting
psych2Go and making this all possible for
us.
Our vision is to make psychology as accessible
as possible so that it promotes self-awareness
and it helps you guys grow.
However, we want to make more content for
you guys and would love your support in buying
one of these bracelets from our partner introvert
palace.
Check out the bracelet, it's pretty cool and
it even includes Pluto.
The link to purchase will all be in the description
below and I hope you guys have an amazing day. Bye.
[Music]